what we're going to do in this videos
give ourselves practice representing
fractions that you're going to see a lot
in life in different ways so the first
fraction we're going to explore is 1/5
then we're going to explore 1/4 then we
are going to explore 1/2 so let's start
with 1/5 so I encourage you to pause the
video and say and think about how would
you represent 1/5 as a decimal well
there's a bunch of ways that you could
think about it you could divide 5 into 1
you could say that this is equal to 1/5
and if you did that you actually would
get the right answer but there's a
simpler way of thinking about this even
in your head you could say well let me
see if I can represent this is a certain
number of tenths because if you know how
many tenths we know how to represent
that as a decimal well they go to from
5th to 10th you have to multiply the
denominator by 2 so let's multiply the
numerator by 2 as well so 1/5 1 times 2
is the same thing as 2/10 and we know
how to represent that in decimal
notation that's going to be 0.2 this is
the tenths place so we have exactly two
tenths
now let's do 1/4 same idea how can I
represent this as a decimal well at
first you might say well can I represent
this as a certain number of tenths but
and you could do it this way but 10
isn't a multiple of 4 so let's see if we
can do it in terms of hundreds because
100 is a multiple of 4 well to go from 4
to 100 you have to multiply by 25 so
let's multiply the numerator by 25 to
get an equivalent fraction so 1 times 25
is 25 so 1/4 is equal to 25 hundredths
and we can represent that in decimal
notation as 25 hundredths which we could
also consider two tenths and five
hundredths now let's do 1/2 same exact
idea well 10 is a multiple of two so we
can think about this in terms of tenths
so to go from two to 10 we multiply by
five so let's multiply the numerator by
five as well so 1/2
is equal to five tenths which if you
want to represent it as s as a decimal
is zero point five five ten now why is
this useful well one you're going to see
these fractions show up a lot in life
and you're going to go both ways if you
see two tenths or 2000s to be able to
immediately recognize hey that's
one-fifth or 2500 say that's 1/4 or 1/4
that's 2500 1/2 is 0.5 or 0.5 is 1/2
it's not just useful for these three
fractions it's useful for things that
are multiple of these three fractions
for example if someone said quick what
is 3/5 represented as a decimal well in
your brain you could say what 3/5 that's
just going to be 3 times 1/5 and I know
that 1/5 is 2/10 so that's going to be 3
times 2 tenths which is well 3 times 2
is 6 so 3 times 2 10 is 6 cents so
really quick you were able to say hey
that's 3/5 is 6/10 you could have gone
the other way around
you could have said 6/10 is equal to 2
times is equal to 3 times 2 10 and 2/10
you know is 1/5 so this is going to be
equal to 3 times 1/5
and once again these are just things
that you'll get comfortable with the
more that you get practice let's do
another one let's say you wanted to
represent what's it you want to
represent so let me do it another way
0.75 as a fraction pause the video try
to do it yourself
well you might have immediately
recognize that 75 is 3 times 25
so 75 hundredths is equal to 3 times 25
hundredths and 25 hundredths we already
know is 1/4 so this is equal to 3 times
1/4 which is equal to 3/4 and over time
you won't have to do all of this in your
head you'll just recognize 75 hundred
steps 3/4 because 25 hundredths is 1/4
and now let's do let's say we have let's
say we have 2.5 and we want to rep
present that as a fraction well there's
a bunch of ways that you could do this
you could say well this is five times
zero point five and that's going to be
five times one half well that's going to
be five halfs it's an improper fraction
but it's a fraction and so once again
the whole point here and you might
already be familiar with different ways
of converting between fractions and
decimals but if you recognize 1/5 1/4
1/2 it's going to be a lot easier notice
if you did it the other way around it
would be a little bit more work if I
said let me convert 3/5 to a decimal
well then you would have to divide 5
into 3 5 into 3 okay 5 goes into 3 zero
times so let's put a decimal here now
let's go to 30 5 goes into 30 6 times 6
times 5 is 30 you subtract and then you
get no remainder so this wasn't a ton of
work but this one the reason why I like
this one not only is it faster but it
gives you a better intuition for what
actually is going on